Dave Chappelle to his great credit
deserves
um I think a lot of a plum for just
going to some middle of nowhere town in
Ohio and then going to the Town Council
meetings to keep like corporations from
moving in and like arguing on behalf of
little pubs and little breweries and
like little restaurants that are there
Dave Chappelle if you haven't looked
into this like has a little to your
point like has he's a I don't know how
much money he has definitely a multi
multi-millionaire Dave Chappelle goes
into this little town uh in the middle
of truly nowhere in Ohio and he just
like saves the city like saves the like
nice genteel like nature of the city and
he actually went and argued against a
huge development that was going to come
into the town because it's been
popularized probably because of Dave
Chappelle and he killed it he got it he
killed it then he bought the land so no
one could developed which is very neat
which is actually uh similar to what you
just described but it it is it it's it's
good we're we're doing a big play with
Times Square on New Year's we're getting
the whole North Tower we're getting a
percentage of it so every 90 seconds
we're gonna have 10 to 15 seconds of the
whole North Tower except for there's two
ads owned by like Coke and Eminem or
something but I was like we should do
things that assert ourselves in these
cultural spaces yes and make people
aware that like we're winning we're
growing we're taking over so that was
like something big we did this year
we're planning you know we're trying to
come up with it with an idea for a bunch
of culture jamming marketing stuff next
year and I think about that I'm just
like you know when I go to these small
towns and people uh this yeah I met this
local guy and he was like you should
consider buying here to help bring
things back and and you know kind of
kick things up a notch there are a bunch
of buildings with the pride flags all
over the place and we both agree we were
talking about it that people are just
doing that because they're scared
they're scared of the violent terrorists
and so long as there is no counter it's
just going to keep spreading people are
going to put Flags not because they
believe in it because they're like this
stops people from beat from attacking my
business yo if I had a billion dollars
I'd go in there and be like okay I'll
buy these three that building that
building in that building and then we'll
get some locals in the community who
oppose this stuff just to create the
space they want to create invest in that
invest in the future of this country I
think the problem is and there was this
guy Nate shout out Nate it's nice
meeting you he said we had a protest out
here and BLM and these other groups are
showing up and none of these like most
of the town it's West Virginia they
oppose the stuff and none of them could
take any time out of their day to come
out and say no to these people and then
I was like that's it right there isn't
it they they won't even show up to say
no that's a bummer so the Passover is
when the spirit of death the right
passes over the households of Egypt and
it doesn't kill the firstborn son as
long as you put Lamb's blood right on
your door this is what Passover is very
high holiday High Jewish holiday uh
still celebrated Christian or Jewish uh
traditions
and so in Washington DC I've literally
watched people do a a metaphorical like
hedonistic Passover on their home so I
lived on Capitol Hill in a very bad
neighborhood where you like a couple
blocks from Jack besobic uh had antiva
come after Jack that famous photo of
Jack like staring down antifa where they
were looking to tear down our Lincoln
Statue there's a statue of Abraham
Lincoln they wanted to tear it down
there were mobs putting you know nooses
around it to rip it down people put up
gay rights flags and BLM Flags in their
yards literally as like a please don't
come here thing I know these people
we're not uh some of them were
Republicans and they were not on board
with this they needed to wave these
flags and put the stuff up in order to
like stop the mobs from coming to their
street you remember Rand Paul almost got
beat like to death with his wife Kelly
Paul outside of the White House after
Donald Trump's speech at the 2020 RNC
convention I got like seven feet from
that watching that happen I mean it's
like it it really is uh terroristic
almost it's domestic terrorism and then
you go back to DC this is my first time
back in a year because I moved away a
year ago I was like I followed I
followed this great podcast faster I
listen to every single day his advice is
he goes get out of the Cities get out of
the Cities Jack masobic must have been
Jack great beard fantastic hat and I
followed that advice we went you know
sort of down to I guess I guess Tampa is
a larger City but it's not like DC I
mean very different from DC in so many
ways I was just back in DC for the first
time in a year man I like the Decay
there's no better word for it there's
just there's there's entropy that is
happening to that City I lived there for
15 years I worked on Capitol Hill I've
asked questions in White House briefings
I've been all over that City and and
I've never seen anything like it first
off there's tent cities
uh as soon as you get into the nation's
capital which you shouldn't have in a
nation's capital right so if you're if
you're visiting from another country you
shouldn't see like Squall or intense
cities and then there's no one there and
the people who are there it's like a
Zombie Town the people who are there
masked like triple masked like walking
around here's a photo from a store I had
to run into a store and grab an item
here's a photo that says um
at uh Nordstrom this is at a Nordstrom
uh rack that said the gas pipeline right
Nordstrom too Hispanic and latinx his
sporadic and latinx welcome here
were they banned before
him why'd you ban the Latino people from
your from your store that's not okay
it's like you these people don't
understand like how to issue a notice to
let people know they weren't doing it
anymore yeah like that's that's what I
got from that the decay in the entropy
is really happening in real time it was
shocking for me to go back oh yeah so
you know I we're looking at setting up a
brick and mortar location probably gonna
be we've been talking about doing like a
community center kind of thing and I've
got these people for one the real estate
markets these the whole Market itself
everything is just insane and they're
trying to get insane away or bad way
it's just insane insane like they're
they're they're they're trying to sell
property for substantially more than you
could even make money off of it's it's
just that you they want to sell a
building it's half a million dollars and
you're like you're in an area with no
foot traffic no customers how is this
money worth anywhere near that you know
even if you if you opened a a chicken
restaurant you would be able to sell
enough to cover the cost of the mortgage
in this area is insane and they're like
it's worth it and I think a lot of it
has to do with these big investment
firms they keep buying up property which
keeps the prices artificially High
nobody wants to sell because they're
convinced it'll be worth it then the
cities start decaying so I go to these
places we had one story where trying to
buy this building and they're telling me
how great at the city is how good it's
going to be and I'm like the local Diner
is closed on a Saturday at noon because
nobody wants to have it nobody can
nobody's working so if I can't even go
to a store and every business is closed
no one is here what makes you think
there's value in this location they're
like it's worth it and it's to me it's
just
it's that kind of mentality that's
stopping people from investing in their
towns from actually building community
and then everyone just sits at home on
the internet and does nothing I don't or
they were raptured I don't know that's
the other joke where is everybody like
you mentioned like in DC like where is
everybody in Florida in DC in DC it's
estimated that 70 000 people moved out
of DC in 2021 and it's estimated in 2021
that 220 000 people moved to Florida so
these are just like rough estimates but
uh again A lot of people are moving
where the freedom usually is more
available where there's less taxes less
government less regulations and a lot of
times that's Florida do you guys see
that video of those two dudes the gas
tanker comes in
and the guy's like you can talk all that
ish about DeSantis but he brought the
gas to Arcadia
I'm a Democrat yeah
shout out to Rhonda Santos for handling
the the potential looting in Florida
after the hurricane because I mean he
came out immediately he was like don't
even think about it yeah you go to a
house you don't know what they got
behind that door good luck trying to
take someone's stuff well they're
insinuating you're gonna get shot
they're armed don't mess with people's
property there was a lot of signs from
the citizens there just you know
themselves saying you loot we shoot good
so that's the culture that that comes
from Florida of individuals saying hey
this is my property hey a lot of us get
to have the right to defend ourselves
and you should think twice before trying
to hurt or steal from another innocent
human this breakdown of Law and Order is
completely insane it's antithetical to
the the culture of the United States
that we would let rioters and looters
destroy the country and then the Flames
grow greater and 21 and you're like dude
I'm not like I don't want Chinese
authoritarian communism I don't want
that but I want to see the National
Guard on the street when people are
trying to firebomb a building I want
them stopped yo okay yo this is wild all
right wild and I have this out the first
thing I got when I got to Florida
concealed carry permit right this is the
first you don't need that in West
Virginia you could never get you don't
need that in New Hampshire but I got one
too blown out I see it this is
of course uh this is this isn't okay see
Ian to your point
so I made my Uber stop uh short of my
hotel and I got out to like look at the
burned down edifice of the White House
now you would say a Betty nobody burned
down the White House well the White
House is a giant ground right and
there's grounds Keepers facilities on
the White House grounds that are
considered part of the White House and
those ground Keepers facilities were
torched down this was the burning
building when the antifa mobs attacked
it was in July attacked the White House
right and they injured some 90 Secret
Service agents and so on and so forth
firebomb the guard post fire barricades
down said fight of the church set them
up 529 Insurrection May 29th yeah we
talked about this so sorry like have you
guys seen what it looks like so it's
still burnt they haven't fixed it at all
it's still burned it's melted to it's on
my other camera because I actually
filmed it to put up on our to put up on
our Channel shout out to Benny Johnson
channel it's linked in the YouTube
please go follow us
um this is insanity they haven't touched
it it's like a memorial to the leftist
Insurrection it's still there I
encourage everybody if you're in
Washington DC to go to the White House
grounds and to just look at these still
burned down the Flint you can still see
the blackened flames of the building
they haven't touched it it's been two
years they haven't they haven't improved
it they haven't tried to fix it it's
just sitting there burned down right by
Andrew Jackson they're right by the
famous shot of the White House right you
see it on the state of the union and
everything and it's this burned down
edifice like a memorial to what the left
did it's almost like they're proud of
what they were able to do when Donald
Trump was in office when they were able
to Stage their own Insurrection I I
don't know if it's like one of two paths
either we we bring in the military to
stop the the Riders this Philadelphia I
keep seeing all the street violence and
Philly shops getting destroyed if we
bring in the military and then we become
some authoritarian regime or if we just
let the mobs take over and then we have
a new a new mafia running the the
country and it's basically young
disaffected men that are gang banging or
whatever dudes Jitters we already have a
mafia it's called government well I'm
talking about local like 17 year olds
that have illegal like yes handguns that
are like legal handguns yeah illegal
like uh uh concealed Epistles that they
don't have licenses for or whatever and
I don't want I don't want the mafia
running the show but that's what it
feels like when I look at videos and
obviously I'm being manipulated by
social media but that's what it feels
like but this is why I say get a cities
it was it was the reason I said Jack
Russell because he was saying that
before I was saying it you know he was
warning people for a while to get out of
cities but I was like yeah you know
sorry Jack well no no I mean we say it a
lot on the show too because we did leave
we were on the other side of the river
from Philadelphia in Jersey and then I
left New York I went there and I said
this isn't fixing anything so we came
out to the middle and sort of middle of
nowhere we're still close enough to DC
but that's that's the idea if these 17
year old kids with their um
constitutionally protected Firearms yes
end up acting a fool and taking over
cities you ain't gonna be there and I'll
tell you this if you're out in Maga
country in West Virginia and something
bad happened it is going to be
substantially better because you're not
going to have roving bands of teenagers
you're gonna have like farmers and their
families and their neighbors coming
together and it's going to be not
perfect probably pretty bad in certain
ways but way way more organized like I
think that as the liberal economic order
crumbles in like the US dollar is no
longer the world reserved people are
falling into poverty living on the
street that is it inevitable that these
cities just turn into Battlegrounds that
it's either going to be the military
mowing people down that are trying to
destroy property or it's going to be
gangs mowing people down because they
want the property like is it one or the
other can we find a peaceful solution in
the cities what do you think
so there was looting in Tampa there was
one incident during the hurricane of of
looters going through going through
Tampa my neighborhood and uh they were
caught immediately they were arrested
immediately uh by the police and then
you could go every single house
every other house and find a homie on
his uh doorstep with firearm
like dad's just got their guns as I sat
outside
and there was not a single looting
incident for the entire like three extra
days of the hurricane because it like
rain it was rainy and windy like what
you mean the police didn't come and save
everybody and protect the neighborhoods
it was the locals who were just the
locals who sat there on their porches
including but I limited to you're
Shirley who's very happy to have a gun
safe now finally and I can build up my
little uh Arsenal here but my neighbor I
come up the street I was at Home Depot
got some um uh uh potting soil right so
this is better than a sandbag so don't
take hurricane advice from a guy who's
just been in Florida for one year but
you can put bags of potting soil up and
they act as a sandbag and they're a lot
more they're like more available and
then you can use them afterwards because
I don't know if you're gonna make it
like a Sandbox or something you can
actually pot your plants right it's
going to be really pretty weather
beautiful weather after the hurricane
so I'm driving back from Home Depot and
I look over here to Johnny is my
neighbor John he's 50 years old Johnny
rides a Harley and here's Johnny he's an
engineer and he's sitting there with his
double barrel like like on his lap you
know I was like Johnny did somebody like
uh send your daughter a naughty DM or
what like what happened right what's the
double barrel about he's like yo there's
looters in the neighborhood no we're
just uh making sure they know not in my
neighborhood and then up and down the
street you see like people
sitting there with their firearms and Yo
No More looting that's the third choice
then it's you don't want the to rely on
the government because they're just
going to become autocrats you don't want
to let the gangs destroy you got to have
the civilians armed and protecting their
individual properties so maybe it's time
in these cities to lighten up on gun
restrictions you will encourage people
to start training you allow a
law-abiding innocent human beings to be
able to defend themselves just like the
criminals who have all the firearms and
I think I know what video you're talking
about uh it was from Chicago allegedly
of of children from from junior high
school and they all had Glocks with
switches on it that made them automatic
pistols uh and uh constitutionally
protected but not legal in Chicago yes
Chicago of course being a place where
they of course have the strictest gun
control laws but you know teenagers 14
year olds are running around with
automatic Glocks and of course the
average citizen can't even have a pocket
knife to defend themselves because
they'll go to jail if the cops find it
on them yeah that's crazy
insane dichotomy that of course is not
fair for the average human being that
it's not fair for someone that is is not
trying to hurt anyone or or an
individual who just wants to defend
themselves that can't and allows
criminals to run free with with yeah
because they'll take the guns anyway the
criminals they don't care about the law
I think what's going to happen it's
going to build up and violence we're
going to see the street violence we'll
probably see more of it as people become
more poor more people in the street and
then a city is going to be like guns are
legal now constitutional carry everyone
can carry and that cities the crime is
going to plummet in that City that's
right you know how hard it would be to
get one of these in DC I tried for years
years in Washington DC to get one of
these there's one licensed firearm
dealer there's one licensed instructor
they can train one person at a time
so DC versus Heller happens right in
2009 2008 2008 DC versus hausler Heller
DC used to be for like 30 years you can
own any Firearms at all decent for
seller overturns this and so what they
did is the bureaucracy comes in and just
makes firearm even though the Supreme
Court said no you will allow the sale
Firearms the bureaucracy comes in and
says okay we'll limit it to a store and
a guy and that person and then and then
multiple police officers that you need
to speak with right so I tried the
process I was drowning paperwork I was
just choked out by the bureaucracy I
could not get my concealed carry in DC I
tried for years it was too difficult it
was too difficult meanwhile on my block
on 19th Street Capitol Hill you could
call it like a gentrifying well I live
right next to a drug dealer right next
to a crack dealer
um that guy had so many guns they were
they were doing open air gun sales
on my street the week that I left the
week I decided to move there was an open
air gun sale going on on the street the
guy opened up his truck and he had I
don't know what he had like a a ton of
firearms sitting there and you know if
you made the right price you just pick
it up out of his trunk right there was a
shooting there was deadly shooting on my
street that the police had to come get
my footage from this was two weeks
before we left right guy gets shot in my
yard jumps into the rose bush
um you know we played on the show a
couple times but what what do you need a
concealed permit for when you can just
hire a an armed security guard who does
all the work for you and and you could
have armed security guards all around
you as you walk around you mean like AOC
like all like all the politicians yeah
and the wealthy individuals who eat at
these Steakhouse and the lobbyists who
don't need to apply for a permit because
they just pay for several men who get
the permits and then
surround them they also got walls that's
this is what they do they the reason why
the these Elites are okay with banning
guns is because guns are only banned for
poor people now it would be hard for
them to get a firearm as well even
though they are wealthy but you pay
someone a couple hundred grand per year
they take the time and energy to go get
the permit and get the guns and they
surround you and you don't have to think
twice about it don't worry you're pretty
little wealthy hat off that's why they
vote for the stuff so that poor people
can't have weapons but they can yeah and
they call for machine gun turrets at the
the capital as of course they tell you
that you can't have a firearm it's
absolutely that's crazy you see the
video of her saying they're shipping the
migrants north but the farmers say we
didn't pick our crops yeah the Florida
Farmers wow Florida
Florida farmers are very she talks like
this and they're saying to me why are
you sending the migrant slept lost we
need them to pick our crops and it's
just like they're here illegally they're
not legally allowed to work and you're
telling me that farmers are advocating
for the commission of a crime to you and
you agree with them uh yo you do know
that Martha uh that that Nancy Pelosi
owns a Vineyard right where yeah she has
a Vineyard this is where Paul Pelosi was
driving to drunk off his ass like uh two
o'clock in the morning three o'clock in
the morning he was going back to their
Vineyard so of course this is this is
this hits home for Nancy okay sure
where's the label are you from yeah
right that's right I picked the grapes
and you wouldn't want the Chardonnay
grapes that are kicked wrong they're not
getting picked with the beautiful hands
okay that handle the grapes correctly
they're getting picked like a week too
late that makes bad Chardonnay and ain't
nobody dislike her bad Chardonnay I
didn't know that does that make bad
Chardonnay I have no idea oh cause you
had me worried I was actually
sympathetic to Nancy I was like oh we
don't want to shine
in Saint Helena California makes her the
fourth richest uh Californian in
Congress as of 2015. I'd like to see how
that's evolved thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there